j'ai 38 ans et j'ai créé et tija qui est
une startup dédiée à l'orientation des
jeunes
âgés de 14 à 18 ans
aujourd'hui donc on est deux moi et mon
consommateur la startup on a lancé début
2021 ça a commencé aussi avec beaucoup
de travail de prospection donc j'ai
moi-même interviewé pratiquement 200
personnes pour comprendre leurs besoins
le but des tigeas c'est de donner la
bonne information à la bonne personne au
bon moment et donc d'orienter les jeunes
dans leur choix de formation et de
métier plus tard
quand vous entrez sur notre plateforme
vous commencez par un test à un test qui
est assez court qui nous permet nous de
déterminer un profil et à partir de ce
profil là on va vous proposer des
secteurs et des métiers qui peuvent vous
intéresser l'idée c'est que vous ayez
accès à la totalité la base de données
en termes de métier et de secteur on
organise simplement en fonction de vos
préférences en fonction aussi de vos
caractéristiques c'est à dire votre âge
là où vous habitez l'établissement dans
lequel vous êtes on va vous proposer en
fait les meilleures établissements les
meilleurs fileurs qui correspondent à
vos aspirations
il y a deux éléments qui sont très
importants dans l'outil qu'on a
développé il y a ce qu'on appelle
l'interface donc ce que voit
l'utilisateur sur lequel on a énormément
travaillé pour que la présentation de la
formation soit la plus claire et la plus
limpide possible derrière en fait il y a
énormément de travail autour de la data
notamment autour de ce qu'on appelle
l'Open Data au niveau français donc
toutes les données qui sont disponibles
sur les établissements sur les
spécialités mais également sur les
métiers qu'on travaille aussi avec des
bases de données européennes en termes
de métier et de compétences
on est en train de travailler avec nos
partenaires pour développer la
plateforme l'objectif c'est qu'elle soit
prête pour la rentrée prochaine donc
septembre 2023 pour pouvoir l'utiliser
avec les premiers les premiers
utilisateurs